this episode of true news is sponsored
by surf shop it's basically an outdoor
browser extension which allows you to
put your mobile device or laptop
anywhere in the world say that you're
sitting there you're thinking hey I
quite like to be able to access
something in America better can I really
access it on the Internet in America
surf shop lets you do that even though
you might be in England or bronzey yes
I've actually used surf shop before and
it is actually really great because it
allows you to do things you wouldn't
normally be able to do online for
instance Brian you love Netflix you and
I both watch a lot of series don't mean
rinse them during lockdown you've been
through I absolutely everything on the
UK Netflix say you want to go around
Matt you want to see what American
Netflix is like Oh surf shop and you're
there it also adds an extra layer of
security on your passwords for those
videos to make sure everything is secure
yeah which is actually really handy
because you know you don't lose your
passwords videos or photos yep
especially the not the really private
ones yeah no one wants to see this is
the only VPN to give you unlimited
access across all your devices on one
account it also makes you anonymous
online so you can change your IP address
is something that people won't
necessarily know so you are pretty much
anonymous when you're going on the
internet so say there's something one
look at our unarmed pawn that could
that's one of the options yeah I mean if
you wanna look at player yeah and you
want people to know then it changes your
IP address food whatever suddenly they
don't know who's looking at it it could
be Brian could be very own and also when
you go away or if you're on holiday then
you can also access stuff that's only
available on UK Internet as well like
BBC iPlayer or something like that
that's handy and so that's why I watch
much of the dear formal words exactly
that is exactly what you can do because
normally that might be blocked see how
happy is with himself I do
yeah look at that I make one holiday at
some point yeah I mean can ever get off
this God for certain island I've never
craved a holidays which in my life as
well Wow the problem is you can't get
off this godforsaken island cuz you
worried the surf sharks might eat you
that's my surf shark needs to help you I
can't believe that you managed to make a
advert about surf shop about your need
for our day also when you use Accord
Jordi you get three months free what
eighty five percent off and it's like a
money-back guarantee as well yeah well
you get 30 day money-back guarantee so
there's no risk if you want to draw out
boom
nor worries but giving you don't say P
so you don't worries me
so we're giving you a great offer here
and the guys at surf shop really are
fantastic so head over there take a look
at what they're doing they're helping
true news become reality become true top
story tatty
was it her she back is she in Newcastle
that means when you dress really shitty
it'll have you seen what she's wearing
Tata isn't a Tatyana if you're going for
like high-end product Tati in what you
want to be calling it where I'm from no
yeah although maybe it's tatay I like
the word dream child size of golf I
don't lose everything what Taddy hotty
toddy Target Potter yeah sorry tell me
so much further back than anyone elses I
don't know what's going on like cut off
yeah [__] hell
she got a waxwork of her she really does
look fake wow this looks like a computer
rendering of what we think tatty will
look like no I'm not having a go at her
for our luck she's obviously a very
beautiful woman oh really
she doesn't look real right yeah it
looks like you know the Fembots out with
Austin Powers yeah exactly but it's been
a long time coming your associate Claud
she's already cried with five seconds in
yeah she's cried long story short right
why why she's crying he's crying just
because she's about to put all the blame
for her torpedoing James Charles on
Shane and Jeffrey this woman he's over
30s putting [__] on so you know
something great for he's kicking foliage
dog looks great for it I mean she does
look amazing
I'll give her that but she's already
breaking into tears and it's like it's
just fake isn't it a normal human being
who isn't a sociopath yeah but I'm not
saying she is one no but I'm just saying
people who are definitely not ones yeah
they take a while to get at that point
not see you've got to go through you
know what happened you start reliving
the emotions and then the tears the
tears are they boom BAM straight away
you go yeah this is what you wanted well
given the people what they want don't
give them at the top of the video though
make them wait for it for it you don't
give the people instant tears you have
aroused by a woman crying that's a
really weird question me neither
right yeah good but I'm glad you asked
yeah just to put that out there for
everyone but there's some people out
there right just sing them sickos who
like I love watching you woman crying
you know what I mean whilst being choked
first off I do want to request something
check this out check this this is really
[__] right actually before that I
just wanted to tell you then I missed
you guys I missed you guys
I miss you guys you know are all you
people have I never [__] it the rock
with yeah yeah I miss you sadly the
reply for most people is sorry a new
number who dis I've replaced you with
tick tock and I'm sorry that you haven't
seen me in a while I'm fine I'm
genuinely I'm fine we're cool
yeah we're good we'll get over yeah well
honestly we got it like that it really
worries me when people apologize for not
being around on YouTube I'm like if
you're really that sorry you'd have
uploaded if you really valued us you'd
have uploaded a video you know how many
breaks we've had in the last five you
[__] nam blue Gordon we sat in a
shitty little bombshell I don't even
live here
I get none of the benefits of this
building I just [__] sit here
sometimes there's a pool don't say it's
a pool downstairs I've been in it once
I've seen you naked once in a year I
hope that Paul would mean glimpses
week-in week-out I've missed this penis
not the [__] anyone watching this that
believes in anything higher than
themselves that believes in any higher
power all higher power all God is love
and the root of love and and I've been
praying every day over this event
scandal whatever you want to name it
this is the most self-righteous [__]
this is such [__] bollocks if you are
actually religious if you actually
believe this stuff you don't do this
sort of thing if God's guiding this
God's had a real he's had a bad game
these other bodies that a man yeah and I
just ask that you press pause for a
moment and even just for 10 seconds just
cover this in prayer because there is so
much healing that needs to take place
she's gonna do more damage later on and
put your [__] hands together and
cover this video in prayer dear God we
come to you today asking that Tati's
video is covered in what Pro prayer pray
and come at sorry love love you grant
her the strength to be able to out not
like that God we know
you're not always a fan of that but out
is it James James star and Jeffrey
Dawson that's one of them outing some of
the community who weren't as nice once
still makeup than her yeah
plate dig up palette stick are the
filaments yeah dear God make sure
everyone buys the vitamins thanks God
yeah and dear God if you could send
those three possibly homosexual men
straight to hell where they belong
with or over yet with their palates home
Oh God amen and amen to everyone at home
yes I'm a grown woman I'm smart I can
usually spot to see a manipulation a
mile away yes I'm a grown person yes I
didn't need to take their opinions and I
could have evaluated the situation on my
own but I didn't hear so she went after
basically a very young creator yeah
she's old enough to be his mother I'm
sure she won't talk to me for long yeah
sure yeah she could be his mother
yeah legally but my guard was down from
being heartbroken and I allowed myself
to be worked by Shane Geoffrey and
others she's really just passing the
book here music isn't it she made a
fortune out of that video she was
peddling those bloody vitamins and they
went like hotcakes
yeah hot vitamins James I am so sorry
that I allowed myself to be poisoned and
weaponized against you oh my god come on
man you went after him you went after
you went after a very young man I'm
sorry that I bought in to any of their
lives leaving those lives and allowing
myself to be gas-lit into making that
video what she's saying now is it's
almost like she gets all the benefit of
the drama without any of the
responsibility yeah so she's trying to
just thought I was Gus lit she on I mean
sure I made wild accusations sure I said
some things that I regret now I'm not
sure I want to take responsibility so
can we all just pray yeah should we pray
about the gas lighting for the world
yeah give me joy my heart keep me lit on
the gas like one thing that he did that
did concern me
a lot was how he would frequently
comment about how much dirt he held on
other brand owners and members of our
YouTube community I believe that he
actually held blackmail material on many
people and was capable of destroying the
entire community she's talking like this
guys tunnels
drama hoon so that's part of it with it
to understand that we need to forgive
the people that he is holding hostage
with veiled threats of exposure this is
where canceled culture is coming full
circle now where the people who have
been cancelled and have done the
canceling and now coming back and going
hold on this doesn't work the problem
being at this point they've benefited so
much from the cancelling they are the
problem she's showing no forgiveness and
nor understanding towards Shane and
Jeffrey and is yet saying so let's not
forgive them for what they've done wrong
towards me but let's forgive everyone
else who they hold down on and it's like
so you're still making targets yeah you
just changed from James to Jeffrey and
shade but you're doing the exact same
thing this video that you did last video
so you claim you've learned your lesson
how about preach forgiveness towards
everyone yeah if you're gonna go down
that road she ain't doing that he's
saying she's a hypocrite
absolutely we need to forgive them
otherwise this won't stop because this
woman has been on our own journey and
revelation suddenly we must all go on
the journey in the revelation whereas
before obviously she was the victim now
I don't know if you remember but always
on true news we always talked about the
drama triangle this woman just pivoted
between different places she's gone from
the victim which was her and James she
then went to the perpetrator when she
was the bad guy against James and now
she's trying to be the hero out there
you go victim perpetrator hero which one
are you and your little argument at home
think about it so prepare to not cancel
everyone can't give them a chance what
makes me really uncomfortable about
videos like this on YouTube is where
people are clearly performing for the
cameras now we all do that a little bit
yeah I'll turn the volume up a little
bit cuz you want to be a bit automated
to get your point across on camera this
is just full-on she thinks she's an
actress yeah this is a person who thinks
they are handling sensitive information
like the nuclear codes she feels like
she's changing she's [__] Kate
Winslet in her she's not yet not that
not and here is Shane Dawson's reaction
the authorities it was because she is a
[__] up I can't I can't I don't want
to save me and things about people this
is insane
this is insane the [__] that he stopped
himself from saying what he thought
about her makes me wonder is he pulling
back as he knows it's the truth oh yes
what we got from this that's believing
brush this [__] yeah if you die in the
truth let's look if he touches his nose
but well he's got his eyes closed when
this is insane you can't accept the
reality let's let's see what you soon
this person literally oh my god oh my
god
okay sorry keep pressing play I need to
get through this video so I can [__]
oh my god
this isn't saying this person literally
oh my god this isn't saying this isn't
so he's struggling to just caught lies
lies lies he's not he's not saying
you're a liar a liar you like yet maybe
he's in disbelief
[Music]
you are so manipulative are we looking
at a situation where we've got Geoffrey
Shane antartic yeah in a triangle going
are they all kind of musta manipulators
in their own winds yeah and they're all
going I've got a gun but I also have a
gun yeah it's filled with makeup I'm
gonna do your makeup really badly I'll
do your voice no this is the thing this
it's a race to who picks moral high
ground yeah and she's playing the victim
she'd got out early so if she would look
to set a store like yeah so and Geoffrey
just sat back and went the PR war
started very good yeah Oh genuinely they
need the cash Geoffrey is the next Bond
villain he happy amazing yeah I just be
clear Shane being also being molested
doesn't take away touchy no I'm the one
I'll see your molestation and I'll raise
use of my own modesty yeah yeah this is
the thing it kind of becomes who's the
biggest victim
they're out trying to out victim each
other more bad this happens more and
more and more in culture and I'm not
having the go of people who are actual
victims of bad things I'm talking about
like you kind of get some sort of award
these days where you you're a victim of
something whatever that might be what it
used to be is we were in a society which
was so silent of people didn't admit
their problems people didn't say what
was wrong with them not when people
first started owning up and going I
the victim of this I have struggled with
this people will cheer them and said yes
well done I'm speaking out and I think
that's important that we do that but
it's also gotten to an unhealthy place
now where people who aren't victims of
stuff potentially could use that as a
way of just being like hey guys well I
might've done this shitty thing but this
also happened to me so yeah yeah the
victimhood becomes the identity and
actually you don't want to stay there as
alluring as it is to stay the victim
because you can always play that card it
doesn't actually give you a healthy life
oh my god that's where I stopped the
video when she starts adding them look I
think he's guilty I think they're both I
think he probably would have said stuff
he regrets these guys are obviously
bitching about each other behind closed
doors they did wind her up and she just
well often did that and it was almost
perfectly yeah is that a fool her though
people talk [__] about each other behind
closed doors but it doesn't mean they're
actually gonna go and try and end their
career she went out and she pulls the
trigger that's the thing if you get into
a [__] group but you're not used to
being [__] when you hear people being
[__] you go oh my god why should tell
someone and they're just so used to the
drama that they all go well that's the
bitching session over back to normal
life yeah she went out and went I'm
gonna tell everyone or no we just say
things privately now I don't know if
they did I think they were kind of
enjoying the fact that she was going to
be the one to do it all for them that's
a good plan and they never expected her
to turn not turn the gun on them
shame then came back into the spotlight
because a few years ago he made some
jokes about Willow Smith who's not the
one who would buy her button for yeah
she's the daughter of Will Smith I don't
a dependent do you know the other news
about Jada Pinkett Smith she had to open
a relationship
yeah used to let her just go and get do
well apparently they're both went and
you know did what they want yeah
relationship yeah absolutely yeah so
what did he say about to Dawson I am
disgusted by you
sexualizing an 11 year old girl who
happens to be my sister it's not funny
and it's not okay so just a [__] joke
then yeah not great joke I don't dislike
chain does that make sense sheds become
a good career and he's become a better
person but obviously back then desperate
for views and attention he did [__] that
was disgusting and I made some crazy
videos young crazy video it's what
happens when you're a young comedian or
someone who's trying to be funny
you get off the mark a little bit I mean
I can't defend it it's just an [__]
moving it he's taking accountability is
than a video Leah for if you've been
watching me for a while
and you know that I have done a lot of
things in my past that I hate because
yes I apologize for a lot of them but
I'm 31 almost 32 those apologies suck I
don't know who that person is anymore
every apology video I've ever made has
been a from fear it's it's me sitting at
home thinking the whole world hates me
and crying and hyperventilating and then
just turning on a webcam and just saying
I'm sorry and then hoping people know
I'm a good person and then it'll go away
this video is coming from a place of
just wanting to own up to my [__] what
you've just told this is that every
other time and you've needed to
apologize you've apologized basically
because you felt a bit bad and everyone
was telling you to apologize it's a bit
like the bull the boys immunes
this time I mean it yeah it's like die
hard this time you might die yeah I'm
gonna apologize for a lot of things that
I've done or said in this video and if
you don't accept the apology that is a
hundred percent okay do you think that's
like a small bit of little psychology on
his part going if you don't want to do
that that's okay kind of giving the
power to the people making them feel
like they're in control
of whatever happens next what a show
he's offering up his mouth he's asking
for mercy there what it also showed was
that before he thought he could do that
and assume that whatever he said is
audience well you have to accept because
I've apologized yeah exactly
the Brahma Tati and what Shane's showing
you they've come from amateur positions
and now they're showing relative
maturity compared to their old positions
but they're still not really mature in
any way have they actually grown as
people or is this just them going mmm
I've got to play this differently now
yeah you know I mean yeah he literally
just said in the past I played it badly
and apologized because of pressure in a
video where he's played it badly and is
apologizing because of pressure well he
clearly didn't really want to address it
yeah why are we going along with this
system of performativity we can still
like Shane when he's messed up that's
fine let's not making I'm bored of
watching videos where people apologize
we get it like you've had a bad past
that we get it you have to address it
and all that
treating you like this is is so
disingenuous and it just comes across as
so fake and empty no wonder people go to
tick tock by the way because the people
over there
brap brap brap brap brap but you need to
apologize for that
you get some of the [__] right over here
we take us off so seriously it's so
boring we're constantly trying to cancel
other people we're constantly getting
into fights tic TOCs just fun I'm not
good at it though here's the other
things not that dude yeah no one's
looking at you as one of those people to
be like no I don't want Shane Dawson and
go I need to work out to be more like
Shane lot of people do lots of property
I mean that's sadly true what has
happened here to [__] guys tall the
girl this guy is a [__] she won't yeah I
think he's a [__] as well I'm really
good yeah and they went okay along with
that no that's what she's like yeah it
was all their fault yeah actually this
is playground [__] yeah we just suck
this Halloween story off no no no
because we made some good jokes in here
[__] indoors the problem Brian that's
the problem with YouTube there are too
many easy low hanging fruit jokes and
that's why we're doing what this bullsh
exactly honestly again
having said that next up Jeff least our
apologizes for the Nazi stuff oh I
didn't do a video though he did it as a
written apology which he means you know
he knows he was wrong if you're a
youtuber and you and you make a mistake
or someone accuses you something or you
doing anything wrong with you ha
defend yourself in the medium not
everyone knows the minute you all of a
sudden go actually I'm not gonna do a
video it just makes you look guilty
it just [__] does cause you're
breaking from your normal everyday
routine and acting completely different
which makes me straightaway go well why
don't you do what you've always done if
you've done nothing wrong why are you
not doing what you've always done what
what the [__] yeah I was just the only
wife you'd see that Jeff restore
lipstick Nancy I just want to know what
was good to reset what he was like
Hitler loved makeup like if Hitler made
a palette I mean for sure it'd be all
white you know what I mean but at the
same time oh my god it would sell so
well the brand was literally called
lipstick nuts worst thing about it is
Geoffrey would definitely be dead under
the Nazi regime he was mocking the flag
I said but now he sees how ugly and
wrong it was right because the flag
thing yeah I get that he also says that
the person he used to be is long gone
I'm also extremely proud of owning an
exclusive makeup brand I celebrate all
races and genders let me just get the
brand in here that person who is long
gone built that brand into what it is
today yes without that Braun would not
know exists right but he is long gone
the brand though over that makes him a
[__] to a nominee still here exists so
who's the lipstick Nazi now Hitler's
grandkids knew he probably fathered an
Argentine because there's a conspiracy
theory that said he'd run away there and
had a kid there probably there we hope
he was that there will be mortified when
the see though yeah what would Grunder
see the Lucy yeah now from a load of
people who aren't actually having that
harder time in their lives to a much
sadder story that happened just the
other day - Byron Bernstein or reckful
as most of you will know him as sadly
took his own life which I think has
touched a lot of people in the online
community hasn't it I didn't know this
guy but I've seen a lot of our myths are
tweeting him and I click on his Twitter
you see that he's only tweeted out a
matter of hours before he's died and you
know he was clearly going through some
stuff when you read his tweets and it's
terrible and you know this is the second
year in a row now an influencer whatever
you want to call us is died this way and
we said last year we only felt like was
women from more common because of the
culture and how negative and nasty it's
becoming and also like the comments and
[__] like that like
when you are talking to yourself as we
all have our inner conversation without
our selves everyday in a negative way
and thinking about I don't want to live
anymore and all these sad thoughts when
you've then got an audience who some
people will be [__] reaffirming that
citee to the voice it can be the worst
place in the world for you so I'm not
saying that that's why this guy took his
own life
but if there are creators out there I
really hope we start saying people take
breaks when this [__] is getting this
bad and looking after themselves more
because that's the only way this is
going to lessen this one particularly
resonates to me because when I started
to watch some of his content he seemed
like such an intelligent nice eloquent
guy when you look at the small moments
that he has those communities clearly
someone that's a very likable character
and it's difficult to see I think
sometimes when you look at the public
persona why
privately someone would be so troubled
it is so sad sometimes it's the ones who
are sort of crying out for help isn't it
people think they can be strong yeah
whilst on this subject I think we should
touch on a zynga video which went out
recently this is little from it where he
actually talks about I don't want to
call in episodes I don't think Ethan's
the kind of guy to go through episodes I
think years he has had some hard times
and his loved biotics foods yeah but a
bad experience and actually you know a
lot of people were talking about our
heartfelt conversation with me I thought
this was quite a sweet conversation
between him and his his friend I've got
in that car with the intention of not
getting back out of it but it's [__]
deep yeah I had the intention of not
getting back out the car that evening
but whilst it was all not only did I put
myself in their job put other people in
danger at that point as well and that's
one of them he's one of my most [__]
stupid things I've ever done in my life
very selfish thing to have done in my
life and not many people know it you can
see there he self-soothing him every bit
of body language about this video and I
say this was like as a guy who cares
about this kid because we've had some
nice hot hot he feels like I can't
believe I'm saying this and I think yeah
good on him yeah for saying it but also
if he is ashamed in any way then there
is no need to be ashamed like is in I
know I know it's hard to talk about
she's naturally gonna feel uncomfortable
but I empathize with how he's feeling
because you know when we did our video
try to stand out of this where we had
that chat start the air you know when
you're revealing
things that you think [__] me I wonder
what people are gonna react like this
yeah it just make you feel credit to him
for saying this in public it's healthy
thing because as I've found out from
talking about [__] where you feel down
and stuff there's a lot of people out
there who think they're the only ones so
when they hear this they're gonna
realize a guy who they I mean people
idolize this guy in the side man it's
gonna make them feel like they're not
alone
I realized whilst I went on that rampage
mission I was like you know what
[__] I do it so what the [__] am i
doing I was like couldn't you imagine
everyone that does actually care about
me if I did do that and I pulled over I
was like [__] I'm going home
doing a hug no I'm alright because I'm
better now man we would have hooked we
would have hugged that's what I was
literally just thinking when it went
whenever we go do you want a hug good
yeah Lola yeah on the back of that there
are also more youtubers who are really
unhappy a on the platform but be with
what they've done in the past and a lot
of people are think about having a break
or moving away one of the biggest was
jenna Marbles who's been a face of
YouTube for quite a while and was one of
the original what she done I'm not 100%
sure but maybe we watch this
et video and they'll tell us jenna
Marbles whose real name is Jenna Mallory
broke down in tears saying she was sorry
for insensitive and unintentionally
racist content she had posted in the
past is not the same person no but I
think it's also a strange way of us
showing that you know when you live with
a woman you work out that actually make
up a non make up can look very different
yeah to be fair that's Jeffrey mean when
they walk I'm not that person anymore
yeah yeah because the makeup yeah yeah
you don't do the shadow under your eyes
are you go yeah exactly yeah although
what I would say is women you beautiful
with and without makeup and I I always
heard that yeah you've always said it in
meetings well I see your face there's
not a thing there
would change cuz huh my from the makeup
just away you take a good fit right into
this amazing little fella who'd the ha
Oh Bruno Mars yeah cookies I don't think
he's gay does he not know can we get
someone on that in the comments I'll be
great I don't know specifically videos
from 2011 and 2012 including one where
she slams women who slept around another
featuring a rap song with the joke about
Asians and one where she John's
blackface to impersonate Nicki Minaj
probably the best time the worst thing
you can do is show all the evidence of
you doing all the worst stuff I read
that because she's getting it out there
going I've done this this is me this is
what I've done and holding her hands up
a bit more whereas and her laptop the
other follow Jesus have been I mean by
comparison [__] well I mean Shane
literally said I don't know I can't show
you those anymore if you want to find
them go find them where she's just gone
here they are I [__] up all right now
from Jenna leaving one platform someone
being taken down we don't quite know is
he banned is he perma bond was just
Russia
you love I quite like Doctor everyone
loves doctor disrespect he actually was
the inspiration to kiss iPhone early
early earlier that was the first one he
watched and I was like this is the guy
I'm gonna use to do the FIFA thing
here's what we know
he signed a deal with twitch not long
ago for a big money deal because they
were obviously scared of mixer taking
him because I'm excited just signed
ninja it was the biggest basically so
they had to make sure they didn't lose
him as well if they had gotten both the
guys that would it would have been
[__] hard for them ninja goes to
mixer as you all probably know by now
mixes gone tits up which is terrible for
people like us who are wanting to
potentially do platform deals and
hopefully one day get signed up off of a
big company because they tried it and
they failed so now we're back just
having YouTube or twitch or Spotify
ninjas now got is 30 million he's doing
whatever the [__] he wants to do
I mean he's living the life that's no
but now Twitter sat there with Dhokla
disrespect on a fat contract or they'd
never needed to give him because there
is no competition now it's not really a
big deal they find some sort of problem
in the card or no I don't know but now
doctor disrespect this band and he is
claiming on his own Twitter he doesn't
know why now that does not feel genuine
I think he has an idea of what the [__]
is going on sure I mean surely you would
but imagine you are such a big stream on
such a big platform and suddenly you get
taken out it's insane there's rumors of
Spotify getting in touch with these guys
trying to serve their own gaming
platform there's rumors of twitch just
targeting doctor disrespect with try me
sure they'd have to pay him all that
cash there's a lot of rumors going
around and we haven't got a [__]
answer we have no idea which wish to be
the news we should know this we're
getting contact all we know is ninja got
paid big time off mixer now we can do
what the [__] that's the only news yeah
and the other side of this is we wish
them well past it go to a big platform
to people who may or may not be good at
which we don't know yet we're
considering making a touched on a book
for now we've been streaming on TG 2 and
also clipping that up on TG 2 so make
sure you subscribe TG 2 we spoil you
yeah enjoy very welcome yeah you're
welcome yeah donut if you want and while
we're on twitch there's been a massive
me to movement over there recently with
a lot of girls coming out claiming that
streamers have done inappropriate things
with them there's been companies exactly
result every [__] has been you know
pointed the finger out over there
recently it's that bad that like we were
considering doing like a some individual
cases on yeah the list is as long as
your arm like it is it ranges from bad
dating experiences all the way to to
rape yeah me your your sat there just
thinking like how the [__] did this
happen in a community which is supposed
to be this wholesome place and people
game together and have a good time and
and I think this has gone beyond twitch
as a company's remit of what they can
control a colony he'll be brought at
this point to make sure people are safe
because I think a lot of people sadly
don't feel safe now in that community
now through all of this there have been
a lot of people who we will miss but not
many people missed J station the guy who
has done multiple mental things down the
years including pretending to be in a
coma once he and his girlfriend's dead
which was the thing that ultimately got
rid of a call and go from the college
but yeah that was a good one as well
he's got the sarcophagus so he's clearly
a Mentalist
and apparently now he's back anyway
because well he's changed I agreed to
give Alexia half the channel like 50% of
the revenue obviously we don't see eye
to eye so you know she was the dead like
he Trevor like [__] like this is like I
wasn't in that relationship I wasn't
there the tip of the iceberg that we've
seen was more than enough to know that
this girl was mentally [__] by this
guy I know some people have arguments
and you have your disagreements this
girl was a wreck by the time he was done
with her obviously we don't see eye to
eye so Alexia's it's probably gonna
think that I'm not being honest but from
my point of view I'm telling you guys
right now I'm being honest if this guy
make good videos and I made a mistake
I'd be like like you idiots awesome yeah
you kind of lien and you go I want to
believe you yeah I don't want to believe
here yeah you can go [__] yeah exactly I
look at it and I go no one wants your
videos back no there's no loss to my
life to not seeing you cold dead people
this is the thing though for you here
like so ever yeah as 14k morons in the
world we all know this this is true I'm
being honest with you when I'm telling
you this that I want to do YouTube pure
you you know I think when I want to show
people I really want to make videos I
think you know what I'll Drive out to
the middle of nowhere in my car and film
it portrait to show people how badly I
want to make videos again I love how
much that triggers yeah it pisses me off
that this guy's I I can't wait to make
videos for you again put some [__]
effort in then this scruffy [__] right
sitting there going I really want to
make videos to scruffy come on [__]
put some [__] effort in then turn the
[__] camera on you sick clearly still
got one he's gonna do the Ouija board
what more do you want good point yeah
very good point I don't think he's a
terrible person I just it really annoys
me when people are sloppy I do that he's
a terrible person she come when
celebrities died and families were
grieving he used to call their souls
apparently and have a chat with them and
make a video about it instantly as soon
as they died he's a terrible person he's
absolutely a [__] I know I was always
coming up with the ideas and putting it
all together and it just felt like I was
giving away 50% he's still bummed
on about the percent with his girlfriend
this [__] what I love about this hated
what I really love about this guy he's
clearly just detailed why he thinks he
shouldn't have had to have given 50% of
the channel away sure yeah but you know
I'm a good guy so yeah it doesn't bother
me but yeah if you're a good person you
just go do that and then you don't tell
anyone I want to make a new series a
live series or I go live the spirit off
coming soon you know I love easy guys I
want to make a live show I go live
you're like oh this is crazy yeah for 90
minutes it really is like the football I
feel like we've got a rival coming soon
yeah this guy wants to innovate this guy
wants to do something nice minutes I
want to go live for an hour an hour
gaming streams five hours drive hours
and investigate stuff investigate
paranormal stuff you can tell when
someone is really good at what they do
when they know all the terminology yeah
when anyone ever says the word stuff to
me I was like you don't really talk yeah
unless of course it's a pizza maker
doing the crust and it's been four
months since YouTube took away my
channel YouTube didn't take away the
channel they D monetize the channel so
if you want to make videos so [__]
badly do it for [__] free you prick
I'm not gonna do controversial things
I'm just trying to do paranormal things
literally put dead celebrities who died
in the past few hours in the titles yeah
to get up in the search engines yeah
Perrineau I was that not controversial
you three yeah but sometimes when these
things need investigating in the hours
after Michael Jackson's death I thought
can I still call this guy do you know
what I mean
yeah you're done with this like okay
fair play well here's some house you
definitely aren't done with Brian let me
introduce you to the new Mia Khalifa now
I've never watched Mia Khalifa porn
before I just want to see what she's
doing so Mia Khalifa just to be clear
wants this sort of video taken down so
it's very normal porn knows far as I can
see it's just your bog-standard yeah now
Mia Khalifa and some of her fans have
petitioned to have the pawn taken down
why because Mia Khalifa regrets the
decision to dupe on years ago now while
she can respect that decision what's
your take I empathize with her wanting
to get rid of the porn like if you
really hear that
much but like it also seems naive on her
part and I know she was naive apparently
she was quite young when she did the
poor and she didn't know what she was
getting herself in she when she gave
consent she wasn't in her right mind
yeah and and she wishes she didn't do it
that's fair like you know what I mean I
feel sorry for her there's certain
things the certain jobs right now porn
is a job yeah and the certain jobs you
do where you just can't take it back for
example you can join the army when
you're 16 you can be at war before
you're 20 you know yeah if you then get
shot and killed you can't go back and go
regret that yeah we can we take that
back or if you shoot someone and kill
them you won't take it back that's the
point is like although you're very young
and naive
you can't take a buck there's things I
did when I was in my [__] like those
age groups where you're like what the
[__] was I do it that's just part of
growing up unfortunately and sometimes
people make bigger fuck-ups than others
and once you've done it you can't really
do much about it it might I'm like if
you want to try and take a role - I
won't fair enough but also like the
internet will prevail
it always does like we can't let's be
honest - I wish those Dame's I had were
off the internet pretty much does it
matter
no it's [__] done now there's nothing
you can do like it's out there you
should grow up and live with it also
like what she's posted some stuff where
she's clearly upset and traumatized by
it and I feel sorry for her she made her
name off of the porno the way Kim K did
she's now got millions of followers
she's got a platform she can make [__]
loads of money because of this so as bad
as that was I'm not saying that this
makes it okay at least she's got that if
she could go back and reverse everything
would she possibly but you can't and
that's just life unfortunately so
there's a position is there yeah just
this for me I know I'm interested to
know what is justice and what were the
wrongdoings I'm also slightly confused
well justice would be that you can
control the image of yourself which
might be fair I do find it a little bit
strange that the first paragraph for
some web reason tells you how much she
was paid compared to the millions of
dollars that those companies make I'm
not quite sure that's the argument that
I've seen many Twitter arguments where
they go three months she was important
in 2014 she was 21 she was paid 12 grand
and the millions of dollars were made
off the videos people get exploit
in the music industry in the film
industry in YouTube I've been there like
people take the piss and when you sign a
contract and you're a grown-up and at 21
you are a grown-up even if you are naive
a few years ago I wish I didn't do that
now can everyone just sort of reverse
like like I think that's what the [__]
my contracts for them we can't change
the law the infamous hit jab video which
was the video that she got famous for
basically collect a lot of death threats
as well and obviously that as put her in
real danger it's strange because she
didn't seem very concerned about that at
the time retrospectively she is more
concerned about that yeah she was quite
bullish at the time but at 21 I can
understand how she would feel a lot more
confident you said if I people who were
going to make loads of money they would
have actor on which she said she intends
terribly and stuff like that I do feel
sorry for ya this I'm not being a
cold-hearted bastard here like it must
be awful knowing that everyone's
watching you do [__] like you regret and
wish you'd never done that's awful
I guess the point I'm making is you can
try and take down those videos from the
internet there's no way you can erase
Mia Khalifa from the inner she was one
of the biggest watched porn stars in the
world for the last ten years like you're
not gonna erase those I wish we could
just like magic one day but you you just
can't like it's not what the Mia to try
her best to piggyback off of what
everyone knows her for and change that
yeah so Kim Kardashian when I think of
Kim Kardashian five to ten years at what
I thought of her and Ray J shagging now
I do that is way down the list because
of all the [__] she's my right she's
gone on to become a billionaire in her
own right she did the [__] with getting
inmates off of death row
yes she's Kanye's wife yes she's a icon
of fashion like she went on a did and
I'm it's easy for her because she's
already got that millionaire family
behind her I'm just saying the best
thing that this girl could do is change
that perception by doing other stuff now
she might not have that in her locker
she may not be able to do that and
that's gonna be hard
so I empathize with that but also you
just gotta be realistic and do whatever
you can do now on someone else you
probably regrets decisions they made
earlier in their life namely Boris
Johnson in 2020 deciding not to
quarantine or lock down just in time
he's been asked he's been a smart
question one that it seems to caught a
lot of politicians out would you take a
knee what do you think his answer is
just prediction take a knee don't take a
knee
yeah tankini shaking as long as there's
no coronavirus in the area I'd be very
happy taking it you think you would say
that Ramallah yeah because you think the
Prime Minister of England would
empathize with the people the people
sort of this job of the e governs you'd
think he'd go oh god I see these people
are suffering and is a bit better system
for a long time of oppression let's see
would you take the meat Prime Minister I
look like what I want to do is well let
me give you Martha I don't believe in in
gestures I believe in substance here's
Boris Johnson the man who doesn't
believe in gestures
you looked up look at these little feet
little face you'll fail tractor look
them sitting on the lovely man's lap
let's watch replay let's watch the man
again who doesn't believe in gender my
dude doesn't believe in gestures
I really wish to do this again but put
corvid on the this is how we're gonna
take a tone smash it yeah but again just
gonna remind you a man who doesn't
believe in gestures just to be
absolutely again I think building a case
here Ross Johnson says UK should clap
for bankers as well as the NHS again
just gonna remind you a man who doesn't
believe in gestures so just to be clear
that these are the bankers who have
ruined us in the past
yeah ruined us I'll take you back to the
financial crash of 2008 this is a man
who says we need to clap for these
people but again doesn't believe in
public gestures he believes in actual
action here's another one first Johnson
here in The Times here is an image of
Boris Johnson making a gesture and doing
press ups let me just remind you Boris
Johnson is a man of substance and not
gestures he also clap for the NHS or ten
big solid and refused to give them the
pea rice right that was literally he
said he's about action not gestures yeah
did the gesture not the yeah the action
again just gonna remind you Boris
Johnson a man who doesn't believe in
gestures here he is ziplining towards
essentially the Olympics and brexit I
don't know unbelievable louvered I
thought he believed he did that
but this man doesn't want to take any
leadership he's a man of substance here
it's the man of substance following if
we look at the de substance of this
gesture Boris Johnson got stuck in the
middle of a zip line for a very long
time so I can't do footprint Dundee yes
he looks like Humpty [__] kunti
here's some evidence of Boris Johnson
and his substance not gestures
I support the easing of restrictions but
unlike the prime mister I'm not blind to
the risks and I don't think anybody else
well a man again making a gesture just
just say clarifier pubs are open this
weekend yeah have a good time with your
gourd
yes in the meantime we're not allowed on
public transport without wearing a mask
I can go in a pub yeah get shit-faced
yeah don't get off me face right bump
into everyone yeah yeah not a problem
right Kong get on a bus without masks
can't even go to a gym god forbid I pick
up a weight that is the definition of no
substance nor consistency whatsoever
one rule for a bus one rule for a pub
one rule for a gym we're all indoors
none of it makes [__] sense now you
may remember from a podcast that we did
not long ago with Sean Atwood he told us
all about the little black book for
Jeffrey Epps yeah we went through the
black book with him long before the
documentary came out on Netflix oh yeah
what is good about that documentary is
it did seem to put pressure on the
authorities to get Guerlain Maxwell as
the person who was clearly the pakora
as David I would say the one who would
go and reach out with these young ladies
and pull them into the circle and he
would then abuse them well now she said
to cooperate with the FBI in one of the
best brand collabs we've seen in years
VI XQ Lane Matt as well she just said
she doesn't have a [__] choice this
[__] has been running from the
authorities for a long time and she's
been telling everyone I'm a victim too
Oh Geoffrey May brought me into his web
and it was as if she was sort of forced
to do this it's always Geoffrey isn't it
how come at every single big event that
Geoffrey went to Bill Clinton's
daughter's wedding she was with Prince
Andrei's and that Peter express whenever
Geoffrey Epstein's of the know God when
he's pictured with Donald Trump she is
on his arm she was his partner in crime
she's his Myra Hindley there's a bit of
me that kind of hits her even more than
Jeffrey now Geoffrey was an absolute
scumbag piece of [__] horrible [__]
deserves to rot in hell the fact that
she would go and get these girls and
convince them to do this when as a woman
you think that there should be some sort
of maternal instinct they are you know
the fact that you're dealing with other
women or young young girls that you
should know better you're you know and
she made it easier for him to do the
damage that he was doing she helped him
every step of the way I really hope they
throw the [__] blue
at her but more importantly everyone's
expecting she's gonna be suicided but I
think that she will have the knowledge
100% that Jeffrey died with she will
know what he knew yeah if not a majority
of it let's be real he was involved in a
pedo ring he was the ringleader he was
setting up very young girls for people
in power and she was in on it the whole
thing that people like Bill Clinton now
will be [__] themselves here are the
allegations all right max well-groomed
three unknown girls all under the age of
18 in London New York and Florida and
New Mexico between 1994 and 1997 she
befriended them taking them to movies
and out shopping and normalizing the
abusive behavior by getting undressed in
front of them herself even encouraged
them to travel to meet Jeffrey Epstein
to engage in sexual act so she used all
those tricks to gain the girls
confidence took the girls to Jeffrey
left him alone with Jeffrey where he
would do all of his horrible [__] and
then she's like oh well it's not my
fault it's like you literally delivered
them on a plate and you know it was
happen and she'd know a lot of what's
going on with these more powerful people
so the only way she gets out of this now
is she sings like six nine which is why
Andrews probably sweating for the first
time ever
Prince Andrew the fact that he's like
I'm not sure if I'm gonna go to America
like how can the royal family be taken
seriously when this guy is just sitting
there in plain sight no one's saying a
[__] word and guess what we're paying
these bastards all of our tax money so
they can if they rich fat cut lives when
one of them is a [__] rapist now Anne
Middleton has had to apologize for the
second time after lockdown because he
called black lives matter scum so he
initially tweeted the extreme left
against the extreme right when did two
wrongs make a right it was only a matter
of time BLM and ETL are not welcome on
our streets absolute scum okay well I
mean he's equated they're the EDL with
black lives matter these are two very
different movements I think and at this
point is proven he's not exactly a man
who speaks for the people this guy is
really like terrible at all so now think
later okay he's awful at this there's
some very bright intelligent guys in the
Armed Forces I don't think he's doing
his best to put foot forward to show
that it's all one good-looking hard on
camera and making people do you know
assault courses sure but when it comes
to deciding what's best for Britain
yeah you're not yeah you're
Middleton you're not in charge am i
still hugging those funds and doing
whatever I want yes
[__] covet nighties now it's like
there's the EDL and block loads but
other same exact things yeah I'm his
publicist must be like oh yeah his
publicist must go how quickly can we get
ant off these books because III really
don't get paid enough for this [__] it's
because people do live on ritalin and I
haven't got anything against him not
really said a couple of dumb things yeah
he said a few things that seem
insensitive and ill-informed someone who
doesn't do his research or just opens
his mouth so it goes up yeah you know
this man is used to acting it's fine now
a man who claims to have done his
research and seems weirdly irrelevant
that somehow has become relevant today
is dr. David Starkey do you know this is
nope he might bored you in history class
in the past with some of his own he's
three documentaries now Bryan David
Starkey appeared on a sort of shitty
live stream for what I can only describe
as bigoted [__] and described this
history of the world slavery was not
genocide otherwise there wouldn't be so
many damn blacks in Africa damn blacks
or in slavery is not that bad a lot of
them survived it especially an awful lot
of awful lot those pesky survivors an
awful lot of these doubt and I'm quoting
here I'm not saying it myself
damn blacks we are alone 99 seconds yet
mental yet nine seconds into a diatribe
by someone that the BBC and other
organizations have paid a lot of money
to become owner or doctor dr. David
Starkey what is he a doctor
I would definitely know racial studies
there's no point in arguing against
globalization or Western civilization
they are all products of it although I
agree with them on that we are products
of slavery in globalization in this
world let's see where David sake takes
this the honest teaching of the British
Empire it's probably the most important
moment in human history and it is still
with us
it's consequences are still on and
generally speaking in most ways actually
fruitful there are downsides again there
were downsides sure a couple of black
people died all right but mostly
fruitful mostly pretty Frisco's [__]
nuts
it's nice nuts now
didn't continue just because I want to I
want to get what shows your well oh well
I'm about to show you the person who has
this guy gives them a platform Brian and
ask for the idea as I said that slavery
is this this this kind of terrible
disease that dare not speak its name it
only dare not speak its name Darrin
because we settled it nearly 200 years
ago why can't we just stop going on
about slavery and that's the point is
that really what a [__] prick now
this guy was given a platform by old
grime bag over here Darrin Grimes the
ultimate prick of all the pricks hears
him prancing around part of London's
Gunilla loss teeny little ass here's
Darren trying to make the case not so
powerfully for why you should help him
Britain's left-wing metropolitan remain
establishment did everything they could
to bring me down for committing the
cardinal sin I've been a young
working-class lad from Canada Durham I
still don't know why you're here
um yeah I'm saluting you're responsible
but there's a far bigger battle raging
across the country now a culture war
fighting for the very soul of our great
country the left wants to tear down
everything that is made Britain a force
for good in the world
this is very guys a little bit dark
you'll notice that this image here is
from a black lives matter protest I've
heard a lot of people like Tommy
Robinson saying this is a left versus
right thing no this is this is equality
that's all this is about this is about
people with different skin colors being
trapped
exactly the [__] same it's not about
your agenda so I'm forcing your little
how can we fit make this into our thing
where I can use this as a left versus
right thing so I'm on this side and
they're on that side and we divide
everyone know this should be everyone
involved saying we want equality if
you're against black lives matter the
other bad guys while we're on that piece
of news have been covering quite a lot
on true news recently one of the
policemen who was present at the passing
of George Floyd is frame walking right
now you you killed somebody in cold well
you do not have the right to be here
no we don't want you to get your status
you want to be like that how do you feel
about her pursuing him in a supermarket
making her feel like that like because
some people would say yes what he did is
wrong but you're then harassing him I'm
not saying that but yeah I think
harassment is a little bit too far I
also think the decision they probably
made to allow him to wander around in
public is a bad idea I wouldn't say I
blame her for a visceral reaction okay I
can understand it justice what did you
do satisfying would I go up in video and
like that no because that's just not the
way that I think justice works I kind of
think that it's a much longer thing
you've got to wait for justice to happen
sometimes you can't always be instant
and satisfying just for you but I also
understand why she's so upset I feel
really and that's the that's the major
point there he shouldn't really be on
now let's talk about people who might
regret more decisions in later life yeah
this girl basically act like a dog but
like the owner basically tells her to do
submissive type [__] you know just kind
of fit what's the man thing give me the
ball give me the ball
[Laughter]
do you know what what really [__] with
me right this girl is exactly my type
thick submissive no no no no I don't you
know sure prefer them a bit more a
dominant yes looks-wise she is very
good-looking to me I find her very
attractive very thick curvy right up my
street and then I'm like what hope do I
have as a month they're crazy [__]
these girls they're [__] I'm sorry
this girl would probably love it if you
soon as she I'll be like wow she looks
lovely yeah you get to know and she's
like yeah I like to do tricks on that
and I like the work give you my poor and
I'm like what what sorry so you say your
peephole I'm like I thought I was gonna
be the weird one yeah what the [__] and
then you go oh my god
you're made for each other and then she
goes can you call me a [__] and you're
like would you like a dirty [__] and
you're like I'm like a female dog oh
whoa whoa whoa and she's just like that
would freak me like this is it during
sex she'd be like ruff I want it rough
Rick Ross
well yeah what kind of dog do you think
she sees herself as German Wolfhound
look at that ass my hips are so god damn
thick that's what I like you wondering
they write they John well how's Jenna
doing University she's earning her side
living I'd say your Foreman thoughts
what she yeah she's in the she's doing
the washer she went to do trying to
drama yes lovely how she doing there ah
ah method acting you want the bomb who
is this then Lawrence well since we
started doing food reviewers and people
as such I thought we get into that again
because we've sort of not been there for
a while yeah we definitely need to catch
up with Google yeah this guy made his
own limoncello for people who don't know
what that is is like a really strong
lemon alcoholic drink most people drink
it in Europe it is sobs nice it's
already quite strong very bitter look
but it's bittersweet I like when you're
like it's exactly like that and that is
what let's see what this guy's reaction
is party people
it is nearly 10:00 to 7:00 in the
evening in the UK depending where you're
watching this it's a Friday night Friday
now mm-hmm I'm about to sample for the
first time my homemade limoncello he's a
little bit Brent isn't he very much so I
like them don't waste any bit week so
hair in it nice chin chin did a search
engine what was this hit yeah where do
the search engines England yeah chin
chin
what does that mean I don't quite know I
think I don't know if it means life chin
chin it I don't know we don't say that
[Music]
I think I might drama Chitty Chitty Bang
Bang yeah the trouble in life the truth
for me
I just really enjoyed that rot folks I
was reading I was the guy who sent us
I'm sure let's start with is friend in
the back garden here's what Dave is now
calling beer garden right folks
June shouting it because the wall just
retake it wouldn't you you just retake
it
just take your June's bra off the line
or a hammock go back I want to say a big
they're dudes boobs are yeah okay
sizable well done was all time wasn't
lovely my here we've got nothing on to
be fair we've got all our orders are
complete up to now it so we're a bit
dead until July that's the way it is so
just alright
it's John a bit slight book still in a
job under stand this my cotton assigned
a [__] word of his min yeah yeah well
we provided we made all the we make a
cable and you know the tubes the medical
supplies we do all that stuff she the
word word Chavis does his impression of
a working-class man yeah Ricky is
imagine like yeah yeah I think next time
we have working on the podcast we have
to show him blue van man and I think he
will make all series based on yeah we
could turn this into the new Pilkington
yeah exactly yeah this mere thing and
then around 25 when I started hanging
around with all the crew builder lads
and that was on the football and the
cricket you become a different person
and then when I became thirty I'm the
obnoxious bastard that I am now where I
do not give a [__] what people think or
say about me it's all those people on
another channel they leave the comments
about me what have we create leaving
these comments but on another channel
and what possible things are they saying
this is amazing he's got beef with some
other food reviewer this other guy who's
like oh I don't like that what Dave's
doing over there some Yorkshire fever
just shows no matter what you do on
YouTube people will find a way to hear
our news something's gone dad
should do this and then another dad has
gone I should have done that yeah that
right research what about people who
leave comments all of the channels
thinking it upsets me please didn't get
to him because he's not he's not taking
on at all let's take a look what Dave
did on his Mabel thought day out I don't
know why even that is enough to make me
some creators leave you with the feeling
and with him it's always positive
oh yeah I like I love his purity the
teacher guerrilla war where yeah it's
such a him t-shirt where he's like I
need heavy-duty clothes real a war so
we're just part chopped ginger is having
a /div he just said gingers having this
slash you and you to this is his
daughter so just in case you didn't know
we've just come by the swallow part
caravan site spits or swallow
oh look out I feel like I'm listening to
my parents thought like you know I mean
remember gingers in the car with them
here they're driving somewhere and he
your dad looks at your mom and goes spit
or swallow and she goes oh small item
just like the like one toward the ground
can swallow me yeah I was there yeah
remember years ago and people have video
cameras and when you go over to the
house they go let's watch the whole
their videos and you get everything but
completely unedited this is exactly what
you'd have like 10 minutes of your
granddad videoing kitesurfing I love it
so that was true news it was make sure
you hit the like button and subscribe if
you haven't already [__] and we'll
see you on the next one